some california democrats they've passed
a new bill
which could help governor gavin newsom
in his recall battle
by moving up the actual voting date our
next guest is a
los angeles restaurant owner and vocal
critic of the governor
since the beginning of the state's
severe lockdown rules
chef andrew gruel from slatfish
restaurant joins us right now
from california chef good morning to you
well thank you so much for having me i
really appreciate it hopefully one of
these days one of these mornings we're
going to be talking things like
pancakes as opposed to the new monarch
wouldn't that be great
absolutely like the good old days well
let's talk a little bit about
the recall how are the democrats trying
to help their governor
well first of all i gotta say when i was
i was just scrolling through i think it
was twitter when i saw this headline and
i honestly believed that this was satire
i thought it was like the babylon b you
know nuisance trying to
use his power in order to change this
but they're moving the election
up um you know or the recall up
and look even trying to put the kind of
partisan politics and speculation aside
i think anybody in their right mind who
would see this would recognize that
whoa whoa whoa something's not right
here if you've got pretty much
absolute power and you're using that in
order to manipulate
or you know re-litigate the rules under
which your own recall
is being run i mean that is just not
the optics alone are dirty for sure
because it makes it look like okay
let's just get this over with real quick
let's see because right now you know
believe it or not even though
he's enacted such restrictive
rules during the pandemic his popularity
is actually
inching up a little bit i know they've
got plenty of signatures
collected for the recall over north of
1.7
million which is all it's about but uh
some say the longer the weight
it could actually allow for new problems
to pop up and that
would actually help your side
yeah 100 and i think the reason and this
is just in my opinion that he's moving
this up is that things are okay right
now right
businesses are opening um you know
people have a little bit of money in
their pocket
and obviously you know by virtue of a
lot of the
money being printed from the federal
government and if he moves us up
i speculate that he's actually thinking
that they might shut us down again
so they got to get this taken care of
while the summer numbers are low and who
knows what's going to happen
moving forward so that's where things
get scary from my perspective well and
andrew it was just earlier this week
that apparently they're saying
in la county they're suggesting that
people mask up again
in restaurants if they're asking people
to do that because of this indian
delta variant they might say we're going
to have to close down the restaurants
again and that's what your biggest worry
is
exactly and that's what i keep talking
about i say look you know with the labor
conversation has been huge across
every single media outlet and part of it
the reason people don't want to come
back to work is also because open close
open close
they're so anxious about a potential
shutdown again and then they hear about
mass mandates they might be vaccinated
and they don't understand why
and now newsom is moving the recall into
this sweet spot
things are a little fishy you know use
my own pun there you go
all right uh he's at slapfish restaurant
he's a chef andrew thank you very much
for getting up so early it's
3 30 in the morning out there and he's
on tv thank you sir
thank you i appreciate